qué tipo de penas podría enfrentar el ex
presidente fujimori y sus ex ministros
mario costa y también alejandro aguinaga
si se confirma su culpabilidad en estas
esterilizaciones forzadas
muchas gracias a lo que estamos viviendo
en su momento histórico porque si el el
gobierno ha aceptado a inicios de este
mes que las mujeres víctimas de
esterilizaciones pueden ser
beneficiarias del programa integral de
reparaciones que es un problema que
siente que se creo que puede la comisión
de la verdad y la estilización de fresa
forzadas no se incluyeron esto es otro
proceso es el proceso judicial que lo
que lo que están buscando las víctimas
es que se reconozca la judicialmente la
responsabilidad de estas personas de
responsabilidad que han tenido
responsabilidad política lo cual también
es es sin precedentes porque se les va a
acusar se le está acusando por tomar la
decisión política de implementar esta
esta política de esterilizaciones
masivas entonces se está juzgando al
presidente fujimori y a sus ex ministros
de salud mal no costa bauer y alejandro
y nada que es ahora candidato al
congreso por el partido de keiko
fujimori
bueno sí sí claro cuéntenos también qué
significó para las víctimas para las
vidas de las víctimas no sólo el haber
sido esterilizadas en contra de su
voluntad sino el haber esperado tantos
años para ver algunos inicios de
justicia en este caso han sido años de
espera y años de maltrato muchas de
ellas tienen secuelas en su salud física
porque estás esterilizaciones se
realizaron muy rápido sin tener ningún
tipo de consideración higiénica entonces
agregan fricciones tanto en salud mental
daños en su feminidad a su cuerpo en
sensación de que las abrieron y mucha
impunidad mucho miedo cada vez que están
abiertos los casos hay algunas mujeres
que han sido víctimas de
de violencia verbal de intimidación por
parte del personal de salud solo lo han
declarado las señoras en gante en cusco
entonces está bonito porque se reconoce
que esto fue una cosa que no debió
suceder
en usted es un país muy racista donde se
les ha culpado se les ha dicho que más
que más querían que se quieren
reproducir como animales y creo que esto
es un reconocimiento de que esto no seas
así que no se te puede pasar por encima
de la dignidad de las personas y
esperemos que qué bueno que se
sentencian a los culpables de esos actos
horrorosos pues esa es la siguiente
pregunta que otras personas podrían
enfrentar o están enfrentando ya a penas
por estos hechos estamos hablando de
médicos enfermeras o funcionarios
públicos de esa época
han habido algunos algunos casos contra
los algunos de los médicos pero pero
digamos no ha habido una ni una acción
legal que reconozca la responsabilidad
por la política de esterilizaciones
entonces tiene que entender que eso no
fueron hechos aislados sino que fue una
política nacional que fue sobre todo
contra los mejores pobres